yeah welcome to this video for round 11
of the candidates in London this is a
solo video again I hope you enjoyed
yesterday's video where we did a dual
friend of mine most of them I not most
all the comments were very positive so
thanks for that um but this this for
this video I'm alone again as usual and
we'll go through the games of today so
let's start with eventual Gelfond this
was arguably the least interesting on
paper because of the sendings and let's
see what happened we had a groom talks
with Bishop f4 this amount shook had
played before against Carlton and he got
a very good position careful tower plays
differently place night efore in this
position Carson played Queen a five
which is the we are the most popular
move your 94 is what term what careful
plate it's interesting the ideas to
immediately fight for the cavity of this
bishop um oops he watch your PlayBook
see one yes III young was was hanging so
this is a good idea and now I'm an
interesting continuation my girlfriend
night 27 he plays this year very
actively and I think this is an
interesting way probably to combat
Bishop f4 besides the main line and of
course it's the prod sacrifice but it's
very interesting what this white
supposed to play he took on d5 by far
the most logical move and I really don't
see him anything else to be honest like
his intention is to take on c3 takes d5
have compensation for the porn but he
took here and Queen a five so lots of
pressure on this on this night timeout
shook when tonight before locking this
and this is what happened looks very
sharp it wasn't done on mandatory to
play in this way black could also
consider to maybe just play like this
it's not it's not terrible black as a
pawn down but he's got very good pieces
very good Bishop active Queen good night
look here ecigs he's got all kinds of
active ideas on and this is probably an
interesting way to play so this game is
not very exciting at the end but still
might be a good way to UM to combat the
Bishop f4 group felt if you play this
opening as black maybe this is something
to to check yeah he took on a to add
command replayed c6 very M direct light
to see five you should be too yeah and
now I'm yeah Bob we should be too am
that you should maybe briefly look what
happened if white plays c4 white plate
see for covering the poor and there's
the very strong loosely five white has
no choice needs to take and after this
with this if I threat it gets very
critical because one problem is that
look at this there's also a big threat
on f 2 so this is very bad for riding so
plate this and after Queen takes d5 the
Queen was attacking this and you played
the bishop f3 tween to c4 with a big
threat you should be too bad
Queen to d5 and back and wrong that's it
draw a grid and well it's it's a
repetition um yeah well not the greatest
game have a basically repetition after
move what is this 14 they played out to
move 17 so it's a bit of a non game but
still maybe it's an idea for black to
look at this um it was not entirely
necessary to to make the draw I mean and
they could have continued with them with
other moves maybe they are not so
correct in comparison to making the draw
but it would be possible so if someone
is black tries to investigate this line
that this is not much of a problem this
is a repetition yeah well you can argue
simply too similar to the game yesterday
offer a job off against Sevilla that
they shouldn't make the draw because of
the regulations but yeah bout to be
honest these are the two oldest
participants in the tournament and it's
been 11 rounds I completely understand
the the issue I think they are probably
very tired and they cannot cannot really
am I'm fight for for the first place but
far not so they draw okay next game is
we shook cause
and this had one very funny moment we
have this position just the same as in
Avant shop against them dad hunt and
hear all kinds of moves are possible of
course takes queen bee three the most
popular ones you should have for the
should be five III know maybe g3 you've
been uncommon but maybe and what does a
good player he plays h4 and this caused
lots of lots of laughter and in there in
the comentary booth because Nigel shot
exclaimed that this is my opening for
blitz chess and bullet chess and grew
shock is playing it in the World
Championship candidates tournament yeah
well how bad is this it obviously has
the idea to play age five and it is not
completely ridiculous it's a bit okay it
cannot refute the groover but probably
you won't be a you want get into big
trouble as right one basic idea is let's
say black castle so just for argument's
sake then white has aged 5 and this is
in fact a bit annoying black doesn't
really want to take with in mind
probably because then d 5 is saying and
wise traded the H pawn for the deep one
which should be an accomplishment so h5
is in a way a threat re threat so black
should do something about that age five
thing one possibility is to to strike in
the center immediately but the question
is if white takes what is happening
Queen a five for instance takes takes
this is a known line
in fact no Linus so maybe the wrong term
this is the known sequence of moves
because it can get very similar White
has played instead of H for Bishop f4 or
g5 this is basically here an extra tent
before white and the extra travel is the
move age four and this is actually a
very useful extratemporal if you look at
this this is the possible line so this
is known but with the poem on h2 and now
white can play age five and this is very
annoying what is what is black supposed
to do here it's it's actually really bad
okay this is just one point of the age
from the thing is it has some ideas yeah
with the quick age 5 or irritating black
with some some technical operations so
cards and obviously never expected this
move and he thought for a while and then
when c6 this is of course there are no
nonsense approach that black basically
says okay I'm playing a slot what are
you playing you're playing age floor
yeah well the idea is to both to the
center and so h5 is just ridiculous I
take it and I'm gone up yeah well okay
and now we should just play Bishop g5
developing a piece and continuing in
rather solid fashion cancels takes and
h5 okay I'm saying in a rather solid
fashion well this doesn't look so solid
but white is only slightly behind
development it's not a big issue and
black needs to take care that you cannot
completely ignore all this so he played
here Bishop f5 developing this piece III
yeah and now black plate of e 6 which
was not strictly necessary but make sure
that there's nothing a bad happening
unknown on d5 he cannot play 97 just for
just to show it it's simply giving up
this porn
cannot do that so he is preparing this
with these six yeah now we shook just
played it somebody took on g6 when cars
will be captured with the bishop yeah
you could argue that this is also
possible but it will always looks a bit
strange because of this possibility not
instantly but the idea and then the
bishop doesn't have any square evo of it
there it gets taken he plays Bishop do
six which is completely fine white
doesn't have anything better then this
move anyway it will take probably at
some point so Bishop d3 97 just
developing any Queenie to and why it
intends to maybe castle long note that
despite of all this white has played a
rare line and surprised Carlton and so
on that he's got 40 minutes more the
clock he just played quickly play no
luluz and didn't try to completely
refute it so on he didn't spend so much
time while we should burn lots of time
yeah in this position um I think I'm
causal should have played differently he
plays now very ambitiously in a way i'm
not sure but this is the right word I
like played be five that opens the
center and it's all off yeah it's a bit
like this very well known known figure
of speech that you should counter some
action on the wing with some action in
the center which is in a way very often
true but it doesn't always really bring
so much advantage as you as you believe
yeah in this case we can look at what is
happening and at the end have a look at
this
all very logical Lex got this isolated
pawn and I guess Carson was thinking
that he's got enough play with the good
bishop and the problems that white still
has a bit with his King it is still in
the middle probably am this is a right
judgment white doesn't have any big
advantage but it feels like white should
be able to maintain a little bit of
something the way he played however it
was nothing I played rookie one first
which was mounted by Queen a5 this is
funny because right now has an funny
opportunity he actually played king of
one but here you must look at your cakes
t5 and this is interesting this is the
answer at first you think this is
completely ridiculous because then why
it takes it's simply blunders rook but
what does not need to take you can just
play king of one honey tactic now the
queen is the same but that's a big trick
coming nightly to check ! and if white
takes there's look the eight going on
this one and this is a very funny cross
pin here very unusual motif and this
leads to a perfectly playable game for
black for example gyuki a five luke t 2
and the combined pressure here on c3 and
b2 plus this problems need to a
completely fine position from black so
it's got ineffective activity to
compensate he went to King f1 rock the
eighth covering the pawn
94 oh very logical Quincy 593 attacking
the Queen return to c6 needs to q5
protected and now we shall play at 95
Quincy 793 2695 and draw a grid with the
repetition the same thing as we've seen
before here it is indeed difficult to
play something else you can but it's
rather risky we sure could try to play
on in a way because this pawn is a
little bit of a weakness but it's not
clear exactly how to continue black hats
got ideas like Quincy for on nights ago
at some point it's it's not easy at all
white can play for example kingi one is
not a great configuration queen here
Queen d2 and somehow continue but it's
probably not very very successful this I
just attempt to to continue black is
active enough those pieces are my active
maybe right is a bit better bit better
somehow but it's not easy he's got 15
minutes you know it's we shock is always
burning time like no tomorrow so it's a
draw and probably this is a fair result
so Carlsen with the draw so now look at
the other games let's do chronic jump
off from Nick one yesterday very
important game against we shook their
Grisha basically handed in the point
with the time-travel induce blunder and
here with white against the currently
last place you'd expect from neck to try
for when he's playing g3 am here which
she did before and I think around
round two or something neither near the
start of the tournament you played this
against we shock and it ended in a draw
and he plays it again here so no bionet
tech or anything of his use of judo
weapons yeah raja baath played with c5
this is an interesting way to play
against the ph cheto variation I'm very
often it leads to the Benoni if white
plays d5 at some point or even to the
bank or black replace b5 and but here
white just decided to continue
developing and wait here very standard
way to proceed us for example something
like this transposing to the symmetrical
English but this is sir of course not
very active for black it's solid but not
two enterprising but job of plays a
different line and this is the line he
had played before takes on default and
Queen c7 and this has a very simple idea
just grab this pawn in fact this is an
interesting line for black i played this
myself in a tournament game couple of
years ago and it really irritated my
opponent and one idea is also if you
look at this move b 3 this is what
Kramnik plate it's not so easy to cover
the pawn this is of course the most
natural way to do it but here on b3
black has a very interesting reply and
this is d5 and that's what Rudd job of
plate he spent lots of time on this not
because he an invented with at the board
here today but because he probably was
recalling his his moose his analysis and
we tried to guess maybe what chronic had
prepared because this has been played
before even better job of himself the
ideas I mean kramnik now plays this move
it's not so obvious this move
but the problem is the following I mean
easiest is why cannot take here it just
loses everything but what about 95 this
is in fact a big mistake the problem is
after takes still cannot take here
because of the Queen check and after
this capture they are various ways now
for black to win material um broke the
ages is one of them with the 8086 but
even stronger in this position is the
move esox taking the bishop and if it
retreats there's Luke the age you need
to first get the bishop back and then
set up the pin and now the movie 5 or 96
coming will win the room the night the
terrible pin put it on the green and on
the diagonal so this is not on white
cannot take even and he can Castle
actually and play technically but
chronic did something else he played
this Queen 85 this is necessary Queen a
five and now I what is right supposed to
do we cannot take on d5 because of a six
and then you will use which he really am
this one intending 95 so black takes and
drops the Queen back so black has played
a number of Queen moves to at the end
return to the aid but in the meantime
he's got a very really am yeah not
ammonia some queenside setup that you
can play against c4 is a weakness and
those lights don't have the greatest of
positions let's have a look yeah it
needs to return him so all this doesn't
look too great for white it still it's
playable position i'm not saying why
this worth but was it some it's
interesting what like
here I think he's got a pretty pretty
okay position played Bishop f5 now this
is not strictly necessary but okay you
can do it from Nick try to improve the
night now you cannot take here this is
embarrassing so night see to improving
the night it cannot stay on the rumor
forever I know knight c6 just developing
93 yeah here blackhead more than one
alternative I'm an active move that's
probably quite okay is here Queen to
deform I think they also discussed this
in the press conference that black had
this auction with his decent game right
now can take but this double porn is not
a big problem it's rather compact Incan
cannot be attacked easily at black got
active pieces this seems like the
possible improvement if you look at the
game continuation he played this one
what still 0 syl oh alright but the
other one is probably museum would be 1
and he hits a bit tricky maybe a black
should have considered to to drop back
he played rugby 8 and funny enough in
this position wyd actually had the
opportunity to take on b7 until it
wasn't bad but it's not very human to
play this way because it leads to
slightly off with peace configuration
chronic played Quincy one getting rid of
this pin what he actually could have
taken now but have a look this looks
really really weird to be honest placing
the look in this way but it seems to be
a quite ok for wider let's say queen
here
here and something along these lines
white could have considered this may be
it slightly better for him it's got
somewhat more active pieces and da porn
on a six this easier to take than whites
a pawn so slight advantage Cromley could
have considered to take but it's simply
not a move from that a human likes to
make of course because you don't want
want this happening so he played this
and now the drama played Queenie six he
also had the option to simply play
Rupert e7 covering b7 and that's
probably the move I would have come up
with just protecting this weakness and
continue to coordinate the position it's
probably am yeah passive is the wrong
word but it's not trying for the utmost
them the most optimal move but it's easy
to play just cover it he played the comp
more complicated he played Queenie six
after which chrome league played rookie
one covering his weaknesses again he had
the option to take em and it would have
been interesting but he wanted to keep
the tension probably a job of not to
conceive oh and now it took on b7 95 195
looks very normal it was a bit trickier
right Dwight had ideas like groups his
heaven pinning again the Queen actually
not the day all night so this is why
Blackie decided to to move this piece to
to e5 it seems that this move would have
been better one point is that this
capture is not really leading to much
the rock now is basically trapped it can
only go here and after this black can
play this funny transformation
and it's a complete draw after for
example this yeah and thus am completely
dead it seems that 95 was better the
problem is he went 95 and here Kramnik
rejected rope cake c7 because he thought
that this would give black too much
activity something like this however
something like this not exactly this
line probably but this would be a
director for black he was considered
that somewhere along these lines black
gets too active with the Knights this is
why you rejected to take very human
approach he played down just Bishop f4
which also secures some advantage black
has got problems with this piece
coordination and still the a bonus a bit
weak went back and age three I think
actually one aim of crumb next move here
Musa um was to play rather quickly keep
the pressure on there's somewhat of an
annoying pressure on blanks position and
then hope that your job offer from gets
into trouble with the time and he's down
on time like 40 minutes less than
chronic night here and before attending
e5 that's why black drop back there was
not much of a choice and here kramnik
decided to earn too yeah change again in
the position Queen a3 was a good
alternative attacking e7 theses and move
that dumb I have much sympathy for but
you played in a more direct way he took
and entered on d5 and this term also
preserves some advantage black cannot
really take this uh this kind of
position you don't want to have its
opposite colored bishops but two loops
on the seventh white is the catch no not
possible played rook e8 this is some
okay night before group t7 now it's
awkward okay look at the time my job is
somewhat down on time rugby 6 and this
exactly is the critical position which
decides the game here a job offer from
could have played the move Roxy seven
which is very logical pinning pinning
the night and what is wyd supposed to do
if he takes a six year there's 97
intending 95 and in fact the only thing
that white can do to prevent material
losses to play a five the thing is let's
make a zero mafia then there's 95 and
this is deadly what do I did through he
needs to oops what this minus was stupid
he needs to UM after this move needs to
play am here he needs to play me five so
that this actually is a pin and white
can remove the Queen let's say here or
do you want doesn't matter inning and
this is now a draw because why does are
able to to take on e5 in the next couple
of moves um let's say here here here and
it all fizzles out
just just one line there are many more
lines that are complete draw like this
yeah and this actually would be the
right of the logical outcome of the game
but the Java fear invested a little bit
of his time I grabbed a two he probably
thought that white will get the pawn
back and we get a draw but II five and
what now night hangs it doesn't have
many squares if you go to h5 for example
g4s the easy reply went to d5 and now
just this move will be to young black
doesn't have many squares if he goes to
a three deaths rook b8 with a double
attack basically on the Queen and on the
rook and this loses the house black
takes where I take this with a big check
so cannot go to a three he must go to a
four and now we have Bishop takes rook
takes and whoops I forgot this sorry
first this of course look before
attacking the Queen went to a two and
now 97 this is the point sorry confused
to move water this is the point why can
take with the check with the fork and if
he takes only seven deaths this coming
up blacks got a terrible back ranked no
way to prevent the yawa it's not made he
can play some Desperados but white is
completely winning this was the big the
big point the trick which job would
obviously missed in some way and okay
needed to
the King now and loses the exchange in
addition queen c4 is quite strong at xf7
and young like it's gonna move needs to
exchange 2pm King f1 and now there's f4
threatening or a look-see to e4
threatening at the end winning even more
material so the job of resigned to him
yeah very sad loss in a way because
after white has rejected sometimes to
take on his heaven which I understand
that you rejected this somehow it seemed
that his draw to chat dissipated and
yeah then he tried this last trick with
the route b6 and good job of took on a
two and hair right for it so yeah but
this is the the fate of the guy at the
end of the the bottom of the of the of
the table if you're in that shape then
then it's a nothing's going to work out
for you matt said simply this way it's a
bit of this journal bit similar to this
german figure of speech from football
first we didn't have any luck and then
we even got unlucky yeah it's a bit like
this okay so three games we already
observed the final game is speed la our
own young so sweet Lara yam the game
alpha the yeah the posture of Magnus
cozy with Blackie Aronian against witla
played an up-and-down tournament I think
he seemed to be in good shape but then
he lost two games against scrum leg and
Carlton and let's see what he's doing
today place de form which in this
context is the ultimate anti marshal or
entire Berlin as Aronian always plays
'if I've against
for so no burning today or or Marshall
in fact we got an Enzo which is a slight
surprise because aronian normally play
some the Queens gambit declined or the
slav of course every player basically
placed the news oh but he does it rally
um and what is footlong up to he plays
the very surprising move a 3 this is the
the sameish variation the same damage as
in the damage of the king's indian and
this is what's will i had played before
the tournament he played the same assure
against the Kings Indian but while the
Samish against the King Simeon ISM in
normal mainline a 3 is really some
backwater it was pretty common move and
numb in the early days of the new minion
even up to the 50s 60s when Botvinnik
quite often played a three at this point
or somewhat later and he had this pawn
structure the prongs structure he is of
course what makes this every move the
yet risky move the ideas all this is
terribly weekend also the squares yeah
weekend on the queenside the samish is
in a way though yeah how to call it it's
it's a bit of them it's like the Kings
gambit of the close games or the names
oh because it's it's a bit it's a bit
risky because the Queen side is so weak
that you very often loose material there
and in addition you need to try to get
something of your chances in the center
and on the queenside yay Aronian go see
five and III here white also can play f
3 which is some the more direct way to
play in tanjung a form and one argument
again this move however
is the continuation at d5 which one
supposes to a position that the normally
is reached them by the move order for f3
not a three but every which is
considered to be quite okay for black
let's meet our players III obviously his
preparation he spent like nothing for
this and here along young surprised yeah
it's counter surprised with the Queen a5
the same move I must admit I had
actually never seen them but it seems
that it has been played quite a number
of times by a strong Grand Master's um
it's not that bad actually the only
reason why has never played already
really rarely played is that like has
some yeah tried and tested main lines
that are really good for him sometimes
unit even black has an advantage um so
that it's quite unnecessary to to have
some some other line prepared but okay
maybe this was a good idea by aronian to
avoid any kind of special preparation
bus villa I would have been curious what
he has in store for the main line um
also because um well I'm writing a book
on the limbs Oh as black ants and I have
something against the same as prepared
as well for the book and it's not
Queenie r5 but maybe I will put this in
and let's say um yeah have put this in
as some kind of offbeat alternative if
you remember if you forgot or your
preparation you can play this it's not
so bad at a tech c3 and white has no
good move that ignores this attack of
course he would like to play something
like Bishop here 92 and so on but Bishop
d3 is simply not possible it loses the
house cannot go here
so the normal move Bishop d3 is not
playable you need to you need to cover
this pawn maybe you can argue that Queen
c2 is slightly more active than what the
swindler played sweetly played this move
it looks a bit passive young rocking
this bishop but i think it's okay
actually um why has a threat here he
threatens Bishop d3 though so we should
be 392 castles before play like in the
normal lines but the queen is silly only
five and this means black needs to
somehow put a spanner in the works and
he plays 94 simply capturing this so it
took some moves but he made sure that
white lost the bishop Pam d6 and now the
interesting moves at forum occupying
lots of space in the center 97-93 and
here black decided to to play in a very
direct manner try to hinder white
advance in the center he played the move
f5 yeah f5 it doesn't turn preventive or
swing that place it right away but black
can make sure that what has not done or
doesn't get a very very aggressive porn
center you wouldn't have gone for f5
maybeee 45 would have been an issue of
the long run so let's put on the move
this is some important capturing with
the Queen this is much stronger than the
really unique we capture with the pawn
it would of course improved White's pawn
structure but on the other hand if you
look at this the black pawn on d6 which
is the main weakness now is impossible
to attack for white and
in fact this seems perfectly playable
this position for black he doesn't have
the serious weakness anymore so this is
much stronger it attacks the depot and
basically will win the deep on there's
no way for black to defended play
castles and now we have this exchange
and what kind of transformation do we
have here see porn exchange for do porn
the big difference of causes this night
this night is an excellent piece only
five controls lots of squares and is
very hard to to dislodge from his very
good post Bishop c8 queen before very
logical so now in this position I think
this is maybe the first step in the
wrong direction hand up not so sure but
anyway here like had a very simple way
to play he could simply exchange and
play Knight to d7 this is very passive I
understand but have a look why doesn't
have much better than this and then for
example on set up something like this
this kind of position um it is very
difficult for why to make any
substantial progress IAM black will go
to e7 maybe play age six at some point
and then he simply place we should be 78
and just sit and wait yeah it'sit's you
will never win this black ok but it's
very hard to break down this position
this was was an alternative but aronian
didn't want to go for that keep this
position in mind it's not great but it's
playable he went back to c7 and with
this he had real
a really outstanding idea but let's see
c5 looks are quite normal this bronze it
gives up d5 but it also makes sure that
like we'll never play on to be 6 and it
gains space for white am so it's a
normal good move yeah TM everyone
expected some I don't know passive but
normal move let's say g6 it's not
spectacular um but ok black with this
continuation needs to defend and defend
passively but it's still not an
overwhelming advantage for white both
players in the press conference said
that they um yeah they judge judge this
position as being only very slightly
better for wide I don't know I mean I
much prefer white but maybe it is still
very solid so hard to make any
substantial progress with the white
pieces however her own and did something
entirely different he played the
shocking move g5 which really was
completely unexpected by by anyone but
pretty probably including swidler i'm
not sure but i would be shocked I'm sure
if this move would be played against me
um yeah and now it's very difficult
swidler needed to react now what should
he do he played the loose c6 which looks
very normal it releases the Queen and it
sort of axel asks black what are you
doing now throttling here to take and
activate all my pieces um in fact here
black had a move to stay in the game and
this is night to d5 amazingly this is ok
if white now moves the Queen that same
somewhere then you can actually take on
f4 with the night and this night
has really good prospects might snow a
compensation for anything here like it's
just better so you after 95 know it
after 95 attacking the Queen you need to
play here this is the idea of white and
this might continue with Queen B 7 and
this moves and all the time there's
night f4 and this is probably needing to
around equal play at the end amazingly
um black is so active with his pieces
that it probably leads to a rather draw
endings at the end White has maybe a
little bit of something whether it's um
it's not enough to get to get a win out
of this he really needed to go 95 what
he played is the equally compared to g5
shocking b5 also move that nobody
expected the problem is if you look at
the press conference that are only on
underestimated the c6 move and and also
miss misjudged it somehow 95 didn't
enter the Hat cm the thing is that even
c6 isn't the best move white could have
played Queenie one with the idea Queen
g3 and this would have been much
stronger leading to a big advantage for
white this is also why g5 is a mistake
not because of c6 there's 95 but here
Queenie one this was very strong with
the idea Queen g3 the idea is also seen
in the game because after be five now
swidler plays Queenie one and we have
very similar procedure as in the line
before black playgroup d5 and Queen g3
this is the problem quiesce queen is
opposite the king and black has no I
move other than age six there's nothing
else here you can try to
play even more aggressively as right but
what sweet as it is perfectly enough he
took on g5 Queen takes a five and
exchange down to an end game where white
has got an extra palm and he's got those
two points which means with good
technical play white should win it and
he did I think a really good job k have
seven first blocking the pond and now it
starts look at for this is strong the
look is very good on the fourth-ranked
it controls important squares it
prepares Bishop to e4 covering the pawn
Adam it's generally a good well-placed
he honored for black activates the rook
to d2 cannot go here of course this is
losing the rook on the exchange rooty to
and now each one again simple move but
strong move it takes away g5 black can
never use the square it gives some space
for the king and in the long run maybe
every one of those pawns can promote
yeah a five and roots III this is also
very strong group g3 group g7 and blacks
king will be the target played rookie to
but this allows a tactic check on g6
black takes f7 and the pawn we promote
it cannot take it this is why he went
back and now look before now now this
mate threatened very often i'm making a
tech decides the factor and learn the
endgame andrew creators just just too
much black must go here the only way to
prevent the immediate mate he took and
roxy five attacking both pawns
yeah of course before you take one of
the points you need to make sure that
you keep your f porn it's very strong so
advanced take stakes and now group takes
d5 with the idea group d 8 after King g7
group d 8 aronian resigned he is unable
to prevent rook g8 and f8 Galindez also
the sea porn so I'm complete completely
winning position yes witla beach aronian
who went wrong with g 5 NB 5 he had two
opportunities here with g6 or here with
the the capture of the Queen which is of
course not nice I'm not saying this is
great but it's a it shows that well
sometimes you you cannot defend the
position with active moves you need to
play passive moves to sort of keep it
together not just trying to to grovel to
a draw and I know it's it's very often
these days that people say well what
would Carlton do we probably would play
and some ugly defensive moves and some
are not loose hehe obviously never seems
to lose these days um his worst
positions for example the position he
drew against Kramnik is is amazing that
that that he is able to to not lose this
game yeah well in the Ronia and he
didn't he didn't really I don't know had
the composure today to to defend this
position and lost a very important game
so the standings this means that
thousands the leads with plus 4 4 wins
and now Cromley against the number one
opponent for him with just half a point
behind just one win from Nick needs to
catch up if thousand plays the draw
and aronian is after that with the half
a point behind kramnik and one point
behind Carson and well tomorrow is the
game of the games yeah it's a Aronian
with white against Kramnik and this is a
must-win aronian must win this game
otherwise he's out of it basically not
mathematically but he needs to win this
and get one of you this is a
qualification event for the World
Championship match and if you want to be
world champion you need to win games
against the absolute best opposition in
the situation where you absolutely need
the win you need to do it it's the thing
that Kasparov was able to do like in
1987 against top of you need to win the
last game in the match and he did and
defended the title these kind of
situations are the make-or-break of of
the world champions so if Aronian wants
to open become the world champion he
needs to win tomorrow it's as simple as
that of course it's only really
necessary due to this this loss here but
he needs to win tomorrow if he manages
then it's still open everything's
possible for him otherwise it would be a
i think a race between kramnik and cars
and cars in tomorrow place with white
against iran shook and he will certainly
try to win the game simply because he
won shook is showing so many
unpredictable time management issues
that he certainly tries to tries to get
a fight out of this and tries to win
yeah thanks for watching I hope you
liked the video I'll be back tomorrow
with round 12 which means three rounds
to go bye